منطقه على بعد امطار من هون يتم ازالتها
كامله نسال الله السلامه للناس من المؤكد
انه الناس طبعا انسحبوا منها ه هذا المكان
طول الليل كان القصف فيه مستمر تم تدميره
تقريبا كله بشكل كامل ولكن باذن الله
سبحانه
وتعالى هذا ما وعدنا الله ورسوله وصدق
الله
ورسوله معركتنا معهم مستمره حتى التحرير
باذن الله سبحانه وتعالى فاما النصر واما
الشهاده واهل قطاع غزه بفضل الله راسهم
مرفوعه
ومعنوياتهم عاليه انما ترى على وجوههم
الارهاق بس ارهاق والله العظيم ما هو الا
ارهاق وتعب بسبب طول السهر وطول
الساعات خوفهم على اطفالهم فقط ليس الا
بينما هم فتحت الارض بالملاجئ وفجاه وفجاه
لقيت لهم جنسيات لقيت لهم جنسيات اخرى مش
هذه ارض الميعاد اللي كانوا نازلين عليها
كيف اجت فجاه امريكا وبلجيكا وبريطانيا
بتقول اولادنا المختطفين عند واولادنا
اللي بتكتب كيف يعني مش هذه ارض الميعاد
ارضهم قالوا ارضنا هلقيت صار لهم جنسيات
اخرى سبحان الله يا لهذا العالم الضالم
شكرا للعرب على هذه الهدايا شكرا يا حكام
العرب شكرا
ش